trying to time the market to buy stock
at the cheapest price is a Fool's game
there is however an investment method
that offers some of the benefits of
buying stock at a discount without all
the risks it's called dollar cost
averaging it's super simple you just
commit to putting the same percentage of
your paycheck into the stock market
every month regardless of whether it's
up or down let's say that Marisol here
decides to put 200 a month into her
favorite stocks no matter the price that
means that when the stock price is
inflated so buy less of them and when
the share price is low she'll buy more
it's an automatic way of making sure
you're paying what the stock is worth
historically and for the vast majority
of investors it has a much better track
record than trying to buy when a stock
is at its lowest believe it or not you
may be already doing this and not know
it if you're automatically contributing
to a 401k at work or an IRA on your own
every month your dollar cost averager
already and if not what's stopping you